[Music]
so a network state is a social network
with a moral innovation a sense of
national consciousness a recognized
founder a capacity for collective action
an in-person level civility an
integrated cryptocurrency an archipelago
of crowdfunded physical territories
a virtual capital and an on-chain census
that proves a large enough population
income and real estate footprint to
attain a measure of diplomatic
recognition okay now you might be like
jesus that's like that's not a sentence
that's a paragraph and the thing is that
there's tons of things which are very
simple to
describe or interact with but very
complicated to implement
and you know for example google has this
really simple interface of you type
something into it but to implement
google is actually quite
difficult
and in particular if you asked me to
define not what a networks it is but
what a nation state is
people will kind of have a tough time
doing that you know they might say oh
it's kind of like regions on the map or
something like that it's a country right
but
when you you want to give like a precise
definition that's not like a circular
definition
the the term nation state for example
first nation and state means something
different
nation
comes from the root word uh same root as
like natality it's like from common
birth you know
and so a nation that's like a group of
people with a common culture like the
japanese people and they have
a japanese language and japanese culture
and they're ethnically japanese and so
on and so forth and the state
is the system of laws and government
that that nation sets up to manage its
own affairs and they're as different as
let's say labor and management in a
factory
okay and the same nation could have very
different states on top of it
there's some you know place like france
is aware of this because they have had
many different kinds of governments and
so on on top
but
in our day-to-day language the nation
and the state are conflated for example
you'll hear her the term national
security or
multinational or
national as a synonym for federal
as national meaning like the entire but
they're actually conflating things
because really a multinational
it's not like
it's operating with the
japanese nation and the catalonian
nation and the kurdish nation and so on
it's multi-jurisdictional it's operating
in
this jurisdiction and that jurisdiction
it sounds like so so the word underneath
has kind of gotten abused
similarly like national security it's
really like state security it's not
really the security of the people
they're sort of abusing a term right so
there's been this drift in this kind of
confusion
and the reason for that is that states
want to identify themselves with the
nation
in the same way that
you know management wants to identify
itself as being the same as labor and to
not have a division between the two now
sometimes that's good and sometimes
that's bad
it's good if management is actually
aligned with labor
and economically aligned and so on it's
bad if management is disaligned and in
the stereotypical case of like the evil
ceo exact with the golden parachute
that's a bad case right
and so in the same way when people try
to make this extremely tight
identification between the state and the
nation
it's not actually the case
the the people can have a totally
different government if they so choose a
shrug it off and that tiny layer of
folks that are in the government
just gets deprecated and a new
government is set up if people pull
their pointers away and they set up a
new thing that's what happened for
example the former soviet union when
when the soviet governments fell okay so
my my point is that
these things that we interact with on a
daily basis we don't usually have to go
to first principles and define them from
scratch right you know if we just talk
about the definition of a nation state
the reason i want to talk about that for
a second is
it will be more clear why the nation
state
is a complicated thing and why a network
state has a multi-clausal definition
because each one of those clauses takes
care of
a different failure mode because there's
all these different people who tried to
start new countries
and
just like a venture capitalist deal will
have this term and that term it'll have
he'll have drag along he'll have
liquidation it'll have pro-rata rights
and so on every single term in this in
this contract
anticipate some conflict or failure that
had happened in the past and that's why
it's a more complicated contract and the
same way this definition of a network
state goes through a ton of different
kinds of failures from
just putting a flag on an oil platform
and trying to call that a country to
going and trying to start a war and so
on there's many different ways that
people have failed to start new
countries
and this definition i think is
constructed to
route around all of them
okay so that's why it's a complicated
definition all right but first let me
just kind of talk about the definition
of a nation-state right and
so first like the the nation itself
we just talked about how that is
you know this this body of people that's
united by common descent history culture
or language and the state is the
government but
even that question of okay fine what's
what is a nation
you can actually drill into it and all
of these thinkers all these famous
thinkers you know rousseau and hegel and
marx and mill all these guys that you
read about in in school who may vaguely
remember it
all of them are now actually something
that an entrepreneur or someone who's
very applied would have to think about
why is that
because if in the 2010s we started to
ask a question that we had never really
asked in the 2000s and that question was
what is a currency
okay
in the 2020s we're going to start asking
the question what is a nation
and it actually becomes something where
you know the thing we took for granted
just a quick question nation or estate
nation first what is a nation okay what
is a nation because
the nation comes before the state
you could have a nation without a state
for example the kurds are a group of
people that have a common ethnicity and
culture and so on but they don't
actually have a state the catalonians
they're in the territory of the spanish
with the spanish state governments but
there are people without a state
and actually when you think about this
right like
the united nations is actually a
misnomer it's more like the selected
nations that happen to have their states
okay there was actually a guy you know
the guy who's currently running
kazakhstan and he's like we can't
endorse the principle of
self-determination for every nation
because we'd go from 192 in the u.n to
like 600 nations 600 because all of
these new states would pop up rather
because there's all of these hundreds of
nations around the world that do not
have their own state
the thing is when you start seeing it
this way it's a lens on the map
that
most people just don't think about it's
a you're turning a constant into a
variable and that is when we talked
about earlier about volatility
increasing
the biggest way that you can increase
volatility is you turn something that
you were a total consensus on and 100 of
people agreed on into something that
only 80 or 70 or 60 or 50 of people
agree on and when you do that when you
take that constant you turn into a
variable
all kinds of assumptions change if
you're a programmer for
example you know
the difference between operating and
assuming that it's just the united
states or just in english versus coding
your program to work in every country in
every language is an enormous change
it can be done but it's like
it's a significant difference concretely
why do i say constants are becoming
variables well there are pc examples i
can point out and there's on pc examples
let's do both
all right let's do both okay well
constant two genders variable and
genders okay that's a great example of a
constant that became a variable where
there was something that was simply an
assumption in the 2000s that very much
turned into a variable and
literally all kinds of back ends and
you know databases had to get rewritten
turning something that was assumed as a
constant interval
an another example is
the us dollar
like before the before bitcoin no one
really thought that
that was a variable
and now it is it's a huge variable it's
something that a significant fraction
thinks of every day
as something that they can swap in or
swap out to at some percentage and it's
no longer you know it's no longer the
thing that you must reform it is the
thing that you can exit from
and
once you kind of start seeing this that
constants are becoming variables
you start seeing it across life and very
roughly speaking
you have
the
you know i'll just use this phrasing all
right but you have the woke and the tech
who are both sort of in different ways
disaligned with each other but also
aligned with each other in terms of
turning all social
constants into variables and all
economic
things into variables let me give the
tech side because it's easier to talk
about
for example
is a meeting
is it in person
or is it virtual now
we have to actually choose right oh uh
are you when you're reading that book
are you reading that book physically are
you reading the digital copy simply the
digital version of everything starts
introducing combinatorial complexity
right oh you're talking to somebody was
it on the phone or is it one of these
like 10 different apps right
are you watching the news well it's no
longer a cbs abc nbc but it's like
whatever number of different things okay
now there's a good to that there's
there's alternatives there's choice
there's all this type stuff obviously
people have said there's a bad oh my god
you know or people are living in their
own filter bubbles really they're mad
that there's more than one filter bubble
but basically this is great
decentralization great fragmentation so
all these constants are becoming
variables on the economic side and tech
is pushing that
and then on the political side woke is
pushing that and lots of things that
people just sort of took for granted
for example
you know the the police right do you
have a society with police people kind
of just thought of that as a constant
and then you have a significant
double-digit percentage of the
population less today but that was
actually saying defund the police right
abolish the police and you have an nyt
op-ed that says yes we really mean
defund the police that's a big variable
right that's a huge enormous change that
is a what i call in the book i call that
a moral flipping or moral inversion
where something that was good becomes
bad or bad becomes good
and when you have something like that
you start to actually create different
nations
because you have the fundamental
premises of what are good and bad in a
population
change and the us is not really a nation
state arguably it never was but it's not
really a nation state at a minimum it's
a bi-national
republic which has the red and blue
nations underneath it and you can see
this there's graphs like for example uh
there's a cgr article
from 2017 that i link
where you can actually see on social
media that the red and the blue are
literally like different clusters
and and it pops out to you you know they
just literally only
link to each other and one way of
looking at this that's really
unambiguous is if you look at marriage
patterns people typically will say that
they will marry
across their race but you know what
democrats will only marry democrats to a
higher percentage and republicans are
tending to only want to marry other
republicans and that is being growing
right and the thing is that you iterate
that out one generation and what happens
that becomes ethnicity
right ideology becomes biology if your
political party is so important to you
that you are not going to marry outside
it
then in like one generation it becomes
at a minimum like protestant catholic or
sunni shiite or something like that huda
tutsi whatever right
you know it becomes something that's
actually tribal as opposed to
ideological the ideology changes the
biology
so these are things where
they're extremely deep questions where
you just didn't even have to think of
them as variables because you're born
into a world where they've been fixed as
constants
you